hey not all the Mozart's paintings were
perfect the end result though that
suckers gonna sell for a million dollars
[Applause]
do you know what's what's funny about
what Andy Reed said what not all of
Mozart's paintings were classics well he
is not a painter right right none of
them were not all of a coach's
soundbites after a gamer match the vinci
songs were very good either you just
have to be smarter than everyone in the
locker room and you're okay right but
but the Chiefs are looking good and
sometimes they win easily and sometimes
they win ugly and and yesterday was a
struggle yeah they need that they do
ready for what's coming they have to go
to New England and play the Patriots and
they're gonna have to win that game if
they hope to have New England come to
Arrowhead Stadium in January with the
potential Super Bowl berth on the line
Patrick mahomes though he and Mike
Tirico pointed this out to me yesterday
oh four nine when following the ball
twenty or more yards in the air
yesterday but they still found a way to
move the ball they did they still found
a way I think that's the encouraging
thing because last year when we saw the
Chargers on Thursday night or Saturday I
can't remember the Seahawks game on
Monday night you know the Patriots of
course and he made a few big plays down
the field against the Patriots I don't
want to take that away but when teams
took that away consistently the Chiefs
couldn't find ways to win those games
last year so I think that's the thing
you take away from this let alone I
thought Andy Reid was just a hair more
patient with the run game and mahomes
was more patient and just not continuing
to try to fire the ball down the field
you know he took what was there to be
hat underneath a few times and just kept
drives going I mean this plays insane
the Harlem Globetrotters okay mahomes
rolling to the right throwing across his
body which is a no-no and then Kelsey
catching the ball and tossing it which
is a no-no and look
Yeah right I mean it's unreal they're
just so fun to watch but the other thing
we need to give them credit for too is
their defense their defense this year is
not a pushover I'm not gonna sit here
and tell you it's one of the great
defenses in football but they give them
a fighting chance when the offense
stalls out a little bit and it caused
two great turnovers inside the red area
Stafford fumble and then was at Kenny
gala day fumbling and the return
touchdown for brashaad Breeland those
are huge major moments of the football
game there were six fumbles in the game
five of them were lost on the play from
Travis Kelce the flip to LeSean McCoy
yeah I talked to Kelsey after the game
and he acknowledged that he was willing
to do that in that moment because of the
influence of Patrick mahomes yeah
because we see Patrick mahomes do things
like that take chances like that and
it's affecting the mindset of his
teammates cuz they think we can take
chances too now you have to operate
within the boundaries of your physical
ability yep but mahomes does it and so
Kelsey sees the opportunity he sees the
guy there let's do it and it's all
inspired by the looseness with which
Patrick mahomes but yeah I mean that
greatness just bringing out more
greatness and other guys I mean I get it
ballers breed ballers and that's what
he's doing they're all trying to kind of
match his level right like you talk
about it a lot like that's what a
quarterback has to do and not only is he
like give them the confidence that hey
we're gonna get it done cuz he's super
talented but it is rubbing off and then
hey LeSean McCoy I mean can we say
something about him gosh is he still
good I mean just amazing what he can do
in the pass game run game but you know
Detroit does deserve credit that game
was there to be had to win that football
game you know Matt Patricia had the
proper game plan they messed a few
things up the Matthew Stafford played
phenomenal and we saw the sat there and
we said whoa I mean what he made some
throws yesterday we were like I think
he's adjusted to the cultured yes yes
and he has adjust right and then any had
an injured hip he was questionable as
hell into the game they had three
quarterbacks active yeah suggesting that
maybe he wouldn't be able to get through
the game he's always been tough
physically yeah and he was threading the
needle and it's a shame because that
would have mean that would have been the
headline for today Lions win that game
that's the first thing we're talking
about the Lions are 300 and one and they
took down the Chiefs yeah watch out for
the Lions
they'd have been in first place in the
NFC North and and you know look now the
challenge is don't give up here's here's
Matthew Stafford still showing optimism
after the loss to the Chiefs I like
where we're going we just got to
continue to work you know just because
one two games tied one it got close on
another doesn't mean a whole lot we got
to we got to make sure that we're we're
doing everything everything we can to
win those games look I do like where the
Lions are now the problem is the Packers
are 3 & 1 the Bears are 3 & 1 the
Vikings are 2 into there's gonna be some
tough games in the division for the for
the Detroit Lions but they showed that
they can hang tough against one of the
best teams in the league and that's
gonna give them confidence for those
games it is and Matt Patricia you know
is showing that he's he's a damn good
football coach he knows what's going on
I mean he does you know he just he
formulates defensive game plans that
slowed down the Chargers slowed down the
Chiefs and they're running the ball on
the offensive side of the ball there's a
lot of things to be positive about the
lines yeah it's gonna be a tough road
ahead but I like their chances at least
stay very relevant throughout the season
all right we're gonna do our Monday
drafts plan PFT live continues right
after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports